السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره كشف تحقيق برنامج ما خفي اعظم
الذي بث لليله على الجزيره عن تفاصيله
ومشاهد حصريه لعمليات نفذها مقاتلوكتيبه
جنين واعرين لوصود بالضفه الغربيه ضد قوات
الاحتلال والمستوطنين التحقيق هو عرض لقطه
تنشر لاول مره عكست التطور الذي شهدته
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الذراع
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه
عرين الاسود في نابلس
توعد قائد اسرائيل القدس الجناح العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي اكرم العجوري بمزيد من
المقاتلين وكشف عن اختراق السرايا للشباك
عبر مجندين مزدوجين
من جانبه طالبات قائد مجموعه عرين الاسود
في نابلس سلطه الفلسطينيه بالافراج عن
المعتقل لديها مصعب اشتيا وهو احد نشطاء
العاريين من البرزين
والتوقف عن ملاحقه افراد المجموعه وكشف
ابو فلسطين في مقابله حصريه لبرنامج ما
خفيه اعظم عن عروض بحوافذ ماليه وامتيازات
انطلاقاها عنصر العرين من السلطه
الفلسطينيه لتسليم سلاحهم مقابل الحفاظ
على حياتهم
صدق المجلس الامني والوزاري والاسرائيلي
والمصغر على فرض عقوبات على السلطه
الفلسطينيه بسبب توجهها لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه الاسبوع الماضي تشمل خصما نحوي 39
مليون دولار من عائلات الضرائب المستحقه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه
وتحويلها لعائلات اسرائيليين اصيبوا في
عمليات نفذها فلسطينيون وتجميل
الانشاءاتها الفلسطينيه فيما تعرف
بالمناطق الجيم بالضفه الغربيه
وقد دانت الخليجيه الفلسطينيه والاجراءات
العقابيه الاسرائيليه واكدت ان اجراءات
الاحتلال لن تثنيه الشعب الفلسطيني
وقيادته عن مواصله الحركه السياسيه
والقانوني لانهاء الاحتلال
تبادلت القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه تقسم
واقعهم رغم اعلان من جانب واحد بمناسبه
اعياد الميلاد وقال المتحدث باسمي هيئه
الاركان الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه شنته
امس الاول ثلاثه عشره ضربه استهدفت بشكل
اساسي البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
من جهتها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها اضطرت لتدمير مواقع تابعه للجيش
الاوكراني بعد قصفها مواقع روسيه عقب دخول
الهدنه حيز التنفي وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزراء ايجار كوناشن كوفينال جيشال
الاوكرانيه وصله قصف تجمعات السكانيه
ومواقع الجيش الروسي رغم التزام القوات
الروسيه بالهدنه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وصولها قطار
يحمل وجنودا والمعدات روسيه الى بلاروسيا
واضافه الوزاره ان القوه الروسيه
البيلاروسيا المشتركه هي على اتم
الاستعداد للدفاع عن حدود ما سمته دوله
الاتحاد في غضون ذلك قال منسق والسياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جزء من
الهدنه ثلاثيه اعلنتها روسيا من جانب واحد
في اوكرانيا هي محاوله من موسكو لكسب
الوقت واعاده تجميع قوتها قالت الصين
وانها تعارض بحزم عبور المدمر الامريكيه
تايوان اول امس ودعت واشنطن الى الكافيه
فورا عن تصعيد التوتر في المنطقه
واكد الجيش والصيني انه نشر قواته لمراقبه
لمرور السفينه الامريكيه في المنطقه
وفي واشنطن قلم مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سوليفان ان منع نشوب حرب في
مضيق تايوان يتطلب الدبلوماسيه مع الصين
ويجب جعل ذلك اولويه واكد سوليبان وجوده
خطر وجوب اسراء لكنه قال انه من خلال
الاشراف المسؤول يمكن ضمانه عدم حدوث ذلك
قامت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]